people are always wondering why by
wearing gauged married well you can stop
wondering now because bindi Irwin is
officially off the market it kind of
like my soul mate
the daughter of the late Steve Irwin
turned 21 on Wednesday and took to
social media to announce that she and
her longtime boyfriend
Chandler Powell got engaged at the
Australia Zoo I'm really grateful to
have found you I think I could be with
anyone else bindi shared these sweet
engagement pics with her 22 year old
fiance showing off her stunning new
engagement bling she captioned the pics
quote on my birthday I said yes and
forever to the love of my life Chandler
close to six years ago I fell in love
with you and every day since has been a
whirlwind of adventure and true
happiness here's to a lifetime of
friendship purpose and unconditional
love it's nice because every day is an
adventure Chandler also shared the happy
news on Instagram posting this cuddled
up shot and writing she said yes
proposing in her very favorite place in
the zoo surrounded by animals seemed
like the perfect way to embark on this
incredible new chapter in our lives
ET was with bindi and her family in may
where she gushed over her love saying
she thinks her dad would approve now I
know you guys have all been spending a
lot of time together Chandler's been
with you every step of the way what do
you think Dad would have thought of that
great guy oh I I hope you'd liked him I
think he would I mean Taylor's wonderful
he's always up for the challenge from
jumping on crocodiles to getting his
little cocky bow tie on you know he's
doing good so I hope dad would love
canva and you know we all love him so I
don't know what do you think about Mike
I think I think he's great I think I
think your dad would have tested him
yeah morning noon and night and then
approved because your dad was kind of
like that dad always used to say if
you're gonna date a guy he has to cross
the kruk pond fast like swim across the
crockpot and thankfully Chandler was a
wakeboarder so you know what
wakeboarding across the crockpot I'm
sure he would have passed the best
[Music]
[Applause]